you do not want to do this trust me ah
drop it
wait haven't you away that's coffee
what's up everyone that trailer was
crazy I know I said in the last trailer
breakdown that I did that the last
trailer was the best one I stand
corrected this was definitely the best
trailer the pure action in this trailer
is simply amazing and I think it's
exactly what everybody wants from this
movie it starts off in a way kind of
funny with Eddie Brock and venom mocking
the SWAT team the leader gives an order
for the team to put on their masks in
which they reply with copy in which they
proceed to do so because in the very
next scene they shoot a smoke grenade or
a tear gas possibly at venom but again
Eddie knowing what he can do with the
Venom symbiote kind of mocks the SWAT
team he already tells them you don't
want to do this so after they say mass
copy
he says mask and venom says copy and
which he proceeds to come out and
destroy everybody the action begins and
it's awesome it starts off by them
shooting a smoke grenade at him
venom catches it and squeezes it to make
it explode this trailer is really a
testament of how strong venom is smoke
grenades do nothing regular grenades do
nothing bullets do nothing the only
thing that really effects venom in this
trailer is the flashbang grenades and I
don't think that it's because of the
flash per se I think it's because of the
sound sound has always been a huge
weakness to venom you can see here in
this trailer how when they throw the
flashbang grenades the symbiote gets a
little flustered and parts of it kind of
pop out for a little bit but even then
really doesn't slow him down much we see
him scale the side of a building to
attack a guy that has been throwing
grenades at him he grabs him and throws
him to the ground and then he himself
jumps to the ground grabs the guy that
he just threw down and uses his body to
just completely destroy everybody else
and then he just throws the guy away
again I think that this is the best
trailer that we've seen so far but let
me know what you all think leave your
thoughts and feelings in the comments
below
reminder about the giveaway if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]